لما نقول جعفر العمده يعني بنقول المسلسل
رقم واحد وبكل صراحه عربيا في مختلف الدول
العربيه المسلسل مو بس ماخذ اهتمامه
مشاهدات والناس حبته لا المسلسل عامل حاله
مع المشاهدين قليل جدا الاعمال اللي على
مر تاريخ الدراما عملتها ومع الحلقات
الاخيره وتصاعد الاحداث الدنيا ولعت على
الاخر وترندات وهاشتاقات المسلسل مفجره كل
المنصات وتعودنا انه نشوف اسم المسلسل كل
يوم هاشتاق في الترند على تويتر وفيسبوك
وعلى جوجل لو مو اسم المسلسل فاسم شخصيه
من الشخصيات اللي عليها الكلام دائما
متصدره قوائم البحث يوميا وطبعا الموضوع
نفسه على تيك توك اللي هاشتاقات المسلسل
عليه جامعه حتى الان وركزوا لي على الرقم
اكثر من اربعه مليار مشاهده يعني ترى لو
احد حيجي يتناقش انه هل هذا نجاح او مو
نجاح اللي ذكرناه من شويه رد كافي اعتقد
يعني
جعفر العمده فعليا تحول عند الناس لحاله
مو بس لمسلسل عادي وهذه مو مبالغه شعور
موجود عند كثيرين سواء اللي بيتفرجوا على
المسلسل او ما بيتفرجوا عليه يمكن المخرج
عمرو سلامه كان من اكثر الناس اللي وصفت
الحاله بدقه انك تحس انه الناس ما بتتابع
جعفر العمده لا الناس بتشجع جعفر العمده
فعليا يفتح اي منصه يشوف تفاعل مع الاحداث
عجيب خلينا نشوف عينه
اخلاء سبيل جعفر عبدالله واخر العمر
اخلاف سبيل جعفر
[تصفيق]
عليها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هي
كمان عشان اجيب اخواتي ولا اجيب احمد
مكاوي ولا اجيب مين بالظبط في الشارع ولا
معاك يا سيد بس يلا قوم
بالسلامه
[موسيقى]
ودنيا مشاها احراج وانا اس
افر نجاح العمل واهتمام الجمهور فيه من
اول يوم في رمضان فرض علينا تغطيه والكلام
عنه من نجوم واحد واثنين وثلاثه واكثر
كمان واستضفنا كمان بخرجوا النجم محمد
سامي لكن مع كل التطورات اللي صايره موضوع
صار كبر فقلنا محمد سامي لازم يجي
الاستديو عندنا ونستجبه على اللي بيصير
فهو معنا في الاستوديو فعلا المخرج النجم
محمد سامي اهلا فيك يا محمد
عذبتنا هذا رمضان تعبتنا
بقول لك عذبتنا الحمد لله مين ابن محمد
رمضان احمد داش اكيد هادي ما فيهاش دال مش
حتصدمنا في النهايه
مش عارف مش متاكد
من احنا محتارين يعني محتارين في اذا
هتصدمنا في النهايه محتارين في بلال شامه
ايش رح تصير نهايته محتارين دلال ايش
حتكون نهايتها محتالين في كثير اشياء
وحاسين انك انت ممكن تغدر فينا في النهايه
يعني هو المسلسل دايما انا بشوف المسلسل
لازم يقوم على التشويق ايوه هو انت شوقتنا
هو الحمد لله والله يعني هو اول حاجه اول
جمله نبدا بها الكلام نقول الحمد لله رب
العالمين النجاح من عند ربنا سبحانه من
عند ربنا
احنا اجتهدنا واشتغلنا كويس قوي كلنا ناس
كتير قوي مش شخص او اثنين او ثلاثه ناس
كتير في كل الاقسام كان في روح في مسلسل
جعفر العمده ورا الكاميرا قدام الكاميرا
الناس عايزه تنجح
ناس عايزه تعمل مسلسل يكون بالنجاح ده ده
راجع لان هو اشتغل مع محترفين وبنشتغل
معنا الشطار الحاجه التانيه ان لله الحمد
ان محمد رمضان ومحمد سامي عملوا مسلسلين
مهمين جدا الاسطوره والبرنس
والمسلسلين دول كان نجاحهم استثنائي
فالناس بقت حاسه ان احنا ممكن نعمل كده
تاني ممكن نعمل اكتر من كده وعرفنا ان
احنا يعني دايما انا ومحمد رمضان بنشتغل
مع بعض بالشكل ده وابقى مع بعض قوي
ففردنا على كل اللي حوالينا ان هم يكونوا
في عندهم
ان هم يكونوا جوه الروح دي ان هم يدخلوا
الموضوع باستقتال على النجاح
الكروه كان مموت نفسه الكاست كان موت نفسه
فربنا سبحانه وتعالى ده الناتج بيكون عامل
هو فعليا السوشيال ميديا يعني اليوم
تحديدا مقلوبه كمان بسبب موضوع جعفر
العمده والس بب كلام بدا يطلع انه نهايه
المسلسل بتتغير وان صناع العمل قرروا
يعملوا كده لما شافوا انه الناس بتوقعت او
انه توقعت النهايه
واستشهدوا بفيديو لصفصف حبيبتي الملايين
خلينا نشوفه بس
السلاح
الحقي لساني
يلا
نداء من صفصف النهارده يوم العيد منزلين
لنا بطلوا تعملوا توقعات ما انتم بتتوقعوا
وصفت تشتغل بتتوقعه والحاجات بتتغير
بلاش توقعات النهارده ايه بشتغل اهو
عجبكم كده توقعوا
اقعدوا بس ماشي كل سنه وانتم طيبين
الناس انقسمت تمام شاي بيقول محمد سامح
هيغير النهايه وشيء بيقول ما حد يتغير
النهايه اكيد ولعت الدنيا في النقاشات
طيب يعني
هتغير النهايه عن جد لا طيب ايش الفيديو
انا في مشهد من المشاهد عندي حاجه تكنيك
اللي عايز اخدها يعني عايز اخد زوايا
تانيه في مشهد
فطلبت ان انا اصور المشهد اصور جزء من
المشهد تاني
مدام هاله بتهزر فهو الفيديو اتاخد
بتهزر عشان نازله تصور انا ما كلمتها
بصراحه
ما كلمت محمد رمضان متاخرش يعني الناس
فهي بتهزر فالناس فهموا ان الموضوع تغيير
نهايه
لا ده دي الحاجات دي على الجمهور
مصورها المشهد اللي انا كنت بصوره ده في
حلقه 27 ما لهوش علاقه بالنهايه خالص في
النهايه محسومه طيب كل الكلام الناس
بيقولوه والنهايات اللي جالسين بيتخيلوها
طيب مش مش حتتغير
النهايه ما بتكونش مشهد المسلسل اللي تكون
نهايته مشهد تاكدي ان النهايه بتاعته مش
حلوه النهايه بتكون
مجموعه من المشاهد بالضبط احنا جالسين
بنبني بنبني المشاعر لحد ما نوصل لنقطه
معينه ما ينفعش النقطه دي
نحيد عنها يعني
الفيديوهات اللي بيعملوها الناس يعني
فعليا ايش بتحس لما بتشوفها يعني والله
والله بفرح قوي بفرح جدا وبفرح ما اعظم من
فنان يقدم عمل ويتعب ويشقى فيه ويلاقي ان
ده رد الفعل عند الناس ويلاقي كل هذا
النجاح والحب والتقدير يلاقي الموضوع عدى
مرحله المسلسل ودخل في مرحله انه بقى
تعايش عامل البيوت والاسر مستوى الوطن
العربي وكل بلدان الوطن العربي طب دي اعظم
حاجه ممكن يقابلها الفن في حياته ساجد لله
بقى ويقعد يشكر في ربنا سبحانه وتعالى قدر
ما ما يستطيع
انه نجاح جعفر العمده الان تخطى البرنس
والاسطوره
كلهم اولادك انا عارفه بس انه فاهم قصدي
حضرتك اه جعفر العمده طبعا عند البرنس
والاسطوري
بعده والله زي ما عملنا الاسطوره
الناس سالت هتعملوا ايه بعدي وربنا كرمنا
سبحانه وتعالى وعملنا البرنس وكان بالشكل
ده
والحمد لله ربنا وفقنا فيه ما جينا نعمل
المسلسل ده قلنا محمد رمضان قال وانا قلت
قبل المسلسل قلنا الناس ان شاء الله نجاح
يفوق البرنس والاسطوره وفعلا احنا عملنا
كده
وانت خليتيني بقت زيك اقول للبرنس هو
البرنس هو مسلسل البرنس
هو البرنس صح انا في البرنس همم كان كان
صعب قوي انك تعدي الاسطوره برضه وفي في
جعفر العمده صعب قوي انك تعدي البرنس
يعني بصراحه في كل المسلسل كان صعب اجتهاد
اجتهاد اجتهاد اجتهاد اجتهاد
نشوف ايه اللي كان ناقص هنا ونزود عليه
وايه الحاجات اللي هو في في نوع من الناس
لما بينجح
ما بيشوفش اخطائه ويفرح جدا ويقول والله
انا كل حاجه كانت صح في نوع من الناس لما
بينجح طبعا ايش اخطائك في هذا المسلسل في
جعفر العمده لا مش معقولش عن اخطاء عن
اخطاء الناس مش دوري اقول عن اخطاء الناس
اخطائي ليا انا عالجها فده حاجات بتاعتي
داخليه تماما انا في قمه نجاح اي مسلسل
انا ببقى شايف العيوب وبكتب وبكتب حاجات
كتير جدا عشان في المسلسل اللي بعده اشتغل
عليها اكثر
واحسنها انا في جعفر العمده شايف اني
بدايه من النص وهو اساس المساله السكريبت
واساس المساله اللي انت كاتبه انا هو مهاب
طارق انا قصه وانا ومهاب طارق سيناريو
وحور
انا شايف اني كانت توفيق من عند ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى ان انا نجحت ان انا اعمل
حاجه في جعفر العمده
في بناء قصته وهي دي اللي عملت التفاعل
اللي مع الناس مش فكره ثانيه الله مسلسل
حلو انا بتفرج عليه التفاعل اللي ما بين
الناس والسكرين اتعمل عن قصد اني انا قررت
في المسلسل ده اني اخلي الجمهور بطل
قررت في المسلسل ده ان الجمهور مش يبقى
متفرج الجمهور يبقى مشارك باني انا اقدم
قصه
يبدو بالنسبه لك للوهله الاولى انك سابقه
تفكيري وانك عارفه ان سيف هيطلع ابنه وانا
ببينه في حلقه خمسه في المسلسل انا مصرح
قبل المسلسل مع
اعلامي رامي رضوان اني فكره المسلسل مبنيه
على شخص بيدور على ابنه وابنه قدامه طول
الوقت
فانت حاسه كمشاهد في الاول ان انت عرفتي
حاجه ما حدش عارفها غيرك حاسه انك تعرفي
القصه دايما وقريبه لها بس حاسه ان كانك
شايفه حاجه وقاعده تجري منك وقاعده تجري
ورا زي بلال شامه بالظبط محمد رمضان طيب
المشاركه بتاعه ليد جمهور بطل لان بطل
العمل
حاجه هو مش عارفها وانت كجمهور اللي
تعرفيها ومتوحده معاه ولابسه عبايته زي ما
بيقولوا وماشيه قاعده تخبطي له على
الاسكرين وتقولي له خذ بالك ده اعرف ده
اعرف ده فبقى لك دور فانا حولت كمتلقي انك
مشارك
فده ده ده كان بناء عليه هو الناتج اللي
شفناه اللي هو ان الجمهور شارك في العمل
فاصبح العمل شيء انا مشارك فيه انا عايز
اتكلم انا عايز ادخل جوه السكينه اتقي
الله فينا يعني ارحمنا يعني طب بس انا
عندي لك مفاجاه اذا تقول الو الو
نورتينا
طبعا اول شيء انت يعني اصلا عندك مسلسل
كمال ناجحه مبروك انت كمان النجاح على
العلاقه مشروعه ميرسي جدا الله يبارك فيك
وطبعا انت اليوم يعني عامله مداخله معانا
علشان كمان انت كمان تهني محمد يعني على
النجاح اكيد انت بتابعي جعفر العمده بس
انت يمكن عارفه النهايات عارفه النهايه
انت ما اقدرش اقول حاجه يعني
مختلف في هذا المسلسل ليش الناس كده توحدت
معاه
الو ايوه سمعتنا
يا مي
طيب يمكن الشبكه يمكن شكلها مو سامعه
خلينا حنحاول نجرب معها ونرجع لك طيب انا
كنت بدي اسالك في شويه اشياء يمكن
سريعه محمد رمضان بيقول انه لو شاف
المسلسل بس 200 مليون شخص فده مش نجاح
تتفق معه هذا الشيء انه اكيد اللي شافوا
المسلسل عددهم اكبر من 200 مليون والله
بصي ربنا سبحانه وتعالى كلامنا ان الوطن
العربي كله الحمد لله لك الحمد
لا استحسان المسلسل فده الحمد لله رب
العالمين فمحمد لما بيقول كده محمد بيقول
كده اكيد لان محمد شاف الاسطوره وشف
البرنس وشاف ابن حلال وشاف شاف ان ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى كرم ان الوطن العربي كله
اشد مسلسلات قبل كده فبيقول لك ان ده يعني
في ناس كده ما اتفرجتش فده تعبير من من من
نجم عايز يسعد الوطن العربي كله فبيقول لك
ان ان كل الناس اتفرج ما رجعت معاه انا
سامعتنا الانمي الو انا رجعت اهلا وسهلا
من جديد حمد لله على السلامه طيب كنت بس
الك عن المسلسل انه ايش اللي شايفته قد
كده يعني مخلي الناس متوحده معاه لديه
درجه
انا طبعا عايزه ابارك لمحمد لان يعني هو
مش يعني النجاح الكبير ده مش جديد عليه هو
مخرج مبدع والحقيقه ان هو عمل نجاحات
كبيره قوي قبل كده في البرنس وفي الاسطوره
وفي مع فك الاسرار ويعني حاجات كتير قوي
فالحمد لله يا رب على نجاح السنه دي
وهو مسلسل حلو اوي مكتوب حلو قوي قوي
وقفلات الحلقات قويه جدا يعني انت طول
الوقت ايه اللي هيحصل طول الوقت مغضوضه
على على البطل وعايزاه في حاجات كتير هو
مش عارفها انت عايزاه يعرفها
هو المسلسل يعني هو جيد الصنع من كل حاجه
يعني كل حاجه فيه معموله صح سواء اداء
ممثلين سواء كتابه سواء تصوير كل حاجه صح
لو كنت هتشاركي في المسلسل يا مي كنت
هتاخذي اي دور اي دور تحبيه دور جعفر ههه
بلال
مكروه
الارض
ما عندك دور معيد تحبيه مثلا
هو اي دور مع محمد حلو يعني الحقيقه ان كل
الادوار معاه دائما يعني اكيد
بس حقيقه بجد كل الاضواء كل ناس في
المسلسل كلهم نجوم صح ايا كان حجم
العمل اللي حجم الدور اللي بيعملوه هو
كلهم نجوم مش بحجمه لا لا لا
فعلا المسلسل كل اللي موجودين فيه نجموا
يعني وصاروا ترندات
فعلا طب انا بشكرك يا مي على هذه المداخله
ومبسوطه وان شاء الله المره الجايه تكوني
معانا في الاستوديو وتنورينا ان شاء الله
شكرا لك
ميمنعرض عليها دور في المسلسل اوكي عشان
يعني من الاساس منه شو شوفوا انه احنا مش
دايما بنشتغل مع بعض اصلا
لا هي هي الحسبه دي مختلفه هو كل نجم
بيبقى له وقت بيعمل فيه حاجات معينه
دلوقتي بتعمل حاجات مختلفه دلوقتي بتعمل
في خطوه هي عملت لؤلؤ مسلسلها لوحدها
وعملت السنه اللي فاتت رانيا وسكينه هي هي
وروبي وكان مسلسل بطوله الاثنين مع بعض
انا على الام بي سي والسنه دي لما عملت
المسلسل بتاع ياسر جلال
كان اول حاجه هي وياسر عندهم كم حلوه قوي
مع بعض وعاملين مسلسل فتاوى كان وكان نجاح
جدا تاني حاجه كانت دور قائمه عليه القصه
وقائم عليه الموضوع هو قائم الموضوع على
على هذه العلاقه انما هي النهارده مش كل
الادوار اصبحت تناسبها او كل الادوار
اصبحت ينفع ان هي تقدمها فهي ما كانش من
الاول مطروح فكره ان هي تبقى موجوده في
مسلسل الاربع نساء زوجته
وان كان اني انا انا انا السنه دي كان
عندي افكار وهي عندها افكار انما فكره ان
الناس بتقول محمد ومي بيشتغلوا مع بعض فده
يخليني مش عايز اجيبها في العمل ده
فبيخليها مش عايز يشتغل في العمل ده
اطلاقا انا كمان ان شاء الله نزل لا انا
عندي مسلسل انا ومي بنصوره مسلسل مي انا
المخرج بتاعه تاليف مهاب طارق انتاج مها
سليم انا بصوره كمان اسبوع
والله بصي انا انا مش من انصار هي هو هو
مشروع قائد انا مش من انصار بارت 2 انا مش
من انصار الفكره بتاعه بورتو طب انا كنت
اسهل حاجه على فكره لما عملت مسلسل ادم
2011 كنت اسهل حاجه ادم اما عملت مع سبق
الاصرار ونجح جدا اعمل حكايه حياه كنت
عملت اي الاسطوره كنا عملنا كنا عملنا
شايف كده وبقول لمي وبنصح بكده نجحت جدا
بلقلق وكسرت الدنيا بؤلؤ تقدري تقدمي انجح
من لؤلؤ تقدري تعملي صراحه عظيم عمل عظيم
ولكن هو عشان الانسان لما يجي في يوم من
الايام يبص لمكتبته
تلاقي فيها تنوع مش هقعد اعمل 17 جزء من
نفس العمل عشان اعمل نفس النجاح خليني بدي
اسالك شويه اشياء كده على السريع مشكله
تتر صار فيه كلام على التتر احمد قبل
الجميع مش عارفه ايش الكلام ده ليش احمد
احمد نجم وكل من بالعمل نجوم اول حاجه
التتر هو يرجع لمحمد السعدي هو منتج العمل
يرجع لشركه ميديا هب هي الشركه المنتجه
للعمل انا مش انا كمخرج انا ليا الاشراف
الفني في منتج التتر والاشراف على شكل
الفونت واشراف على شكوى
وبعدين انا شايف
احمد داش راجل عامل يعني في نفس رمضان
عنده مسلسل بطولته على على شاشه قناه مهمه
احمد داش النهارده نجم جيل ومهم ونجم مهم
وقصه الموضوع قائمه على محمد رمضان واحمد
باشا الراجل وابنه جعفر وابنه
بس وان كان احيانا ممكن الواحد يخونه
التعبير او يخونه الكلام او يبقى طمعان في
شيء اكتر فيلاقي حاجه او هي بتقيسها
بالاقدميه كل ممثل من حقه ان هو يتمنى
ولكن دي في الاخر تعقبات وبتاع ده لا ينقص
من منا ولا يزيد من احمد ولا ينقص من احمد
ولا يزيد منه والاثنين اصحاب واخوات
وزملاء في عمل ناجح وبينهم كل احترام
الجده المستمر على موضوع زينه انت قلت انه
ما عندك اي مشكله مع زينب الكلام هذا كله
زينه طلعت في برنامج الان والتصريحات
عمليه كل مكان تقول ما راح اشتغل مره
ثانيه مع محمد سامي خلينا خلينا ننجح في
مسلسلنا ونتبسط بنجاحه وشوف نجاحه مسلسلنا
وبعدين نبقى نشوف قصه زينه
يزعجها جدا
وهي بتقول مش هتشتغل مع محمد سامي ثاني
انا في الاخر عملنا مسلسل ناجح وربنا
سبحانه وتعالى كلامنا فيه ونجحنا واتبسطنا
وعملنا شغل كويس وهي نجحت عملت دور كويس
ربنا يسعدها بنجاحها ويبسطها بنجاحها وده
قرار يخصها هي هي اكيد ليها وجهه نظري انا
بحترمها على كل الاحوال انزعجت انه انت
كمان ذكرت تعاون مي مع روبي انزعجت انه
روبي السنه عندها مسلسل اسمه حضره العمده
وانتم جعفر العمده او على الاقل انزعجتك
بدايه رمضان لانه الان يعني خلينا نقول
اكيد مش مزعوج انا هقول لحضرتك هقول
لحضرتك اول حاجه المسلسل ده في حاجه نقطه
صعبه جدا مسلسل ده انتاج ريمون مقار ومحمد
محمود عبد العزيز اصدقائك جدا
وبحترمهم جدا وصناع شاطرين جدا جدا جدا
وبحبهم من قلبي قوي مش مش حب الدعاء وهما
بيحبوني جدا في رقم واحد انا ما اقدرش
اطلع اقول اي كلمه لان ده مقدرش مش هعرف
اشوفهم لو اتكلمت كلمه انزعجت عشان مصلحه
شغلي بس انه يحصل خلط ما بين المسلسلين
اسمهم العمده
المسلسل بتاعي الاول كان اسمه العمده بس
زودت جعفر عشان يوضح الحاجات انت ما تقولي
شفت العمده النهارده او بتعملي سيرش على
العمده اكيد مش حاجه حلوه يبقى في مسلسلين
بنفس الاسم فانا قلت من الاول قلت ان انا
انزعجت ان ان في مسلسل ولكن ما اقدرش
اتكلم ثاني حاجه روبي صديقتنا وصديقه مي
جدا وانا بحترمها وبحبها واتمنى لها
النجاح
حاجه ازعجتك او عملت لك سببت لك ازعاج
ولكن من اشخاص انت ما ينفعش ابدا ان انت
ولو للحظه تزعليهم لان الموضوع في التاريخ
انا انا عازرهم هو الموضوع كتابته
السيناريو بتاعه قائم على فكره حضره
العمده هو قائم على فكره حضره العمده او
قائم على فكره ان في عمده ست والموضوع
عندي قائم على بيت العمده وعلى العمده
اللي هو جعفر العمده بطل الروايه اللي هو
الموضوع كله قائم على تركيبته
فالحمد لله رب العالمين انا قلت قبل كده
في الاول قلت اني بعد ما يبدا رمضان ان
شاء الله ويبدا اللي عملت تكون موجوده
هيبقى واضح قوي الاعمال وواضح اللي عمل ده
واضح والعمل ده واضح جمهور وده لجمهور
وانا فرحان في الاخر الناس شافت العمل ده
وشافت العمل ده وشافت العمل ده وان في
تنوع ولسه بعد رمضان المشاهدات اكثر واكثر
كمان هتزيد يعني لسه في ناس بيرجعوا بعد
رمضان يعني لما بيروجوا يعني
انت ما شاء الله بعد رمضان كمان عندك فيلم
لا هارلي مش فيلمي فيلم محمد
سمير مبروك هو الفيلم ده لا هو هو عشان بس
هم كان الاول نزلوا الاسم وبعدين الاسم هو
الفيلم ده انا محمد رمضان صديقي جدا
واحنا الاتنين نجاح مع بعض كتير محمد
رمضان في الفيلم انا حصل زي ما نقعد
باصحاب ده بيحصل من زمان على فكره يعني
حسين الامام مره حكالي ان كان استاذ حسن
الامام هذا المخرج العظيم
وجيلو من المخرجين العظماء يقعد مع بعض
يتشاور في مشهد ويتشاور في استراكتشر في
حاجات ويساعدوا بعض في الافلام عشان كده
الافلام كانت بالشكل ده محمد جه يعمل
الفيلم خد راي وظبطت حاجات معاهم في وزبط
حبه حاجات على مستوى الاصحاب مكان تقديرا
ان هم يحطوا الاسم وبعدين انا حسيت ان ده
في ظلم
المؤلف الاصلي للفيلم فليه يعني احنا مش
عشان
انت اسمك كمان مشهور فخلاص يعني بتسهل
الموضوع انه الناس تتذكر اسمك انت في
الموضوع بس كده
وتعبت وعملت شغلها فالعكس انا بتمنى لهم
كل النجاح هم عاملين
وبداوا يحمسونا وبينزلوا لنا الاغاني
ان شاء الله اكيد هم الاثنين رائعين وانت
رائع يا محمد يعني حمست انا انت مخرج ونجم
وكاتب رائع انت رائع عيش تنحى في رمضان
والله انا بحبك وبحترمك جدا لانك فعلا
بتدي طاقه ايجابيه ويعني وانا من الناس
اللي بيعملوا فيديوهات دول بقعد اصرخ في
البيت ولا لا ههه هو نفس الحركات دي ههه
بشكرك يا محمد وكان معنا المخرج النجم
محمد سامي شكرا لك